l'image que vous voyez ici est celle du
suaire de turin
il s'agit d'un grand drap sur lequel on
peut distinguer l'image d'un homme barbu
aux cheveux mi-longs et présentant des
blessures caractéristiques au visage au
poignet au pied ainsi que de multiples
tâches tout autour de cuir chevelu
ce linceul conservé depuis le 16e siècle
dans la cathédrale de turin a longtemps
été vénérée comme une relique
il s'agirait en effet du drap dans
lequel aurait été enveloppé le christ
après la crucifixion
mais le 13 octobre 1988
une datation au carbone 14 a rendu son
verdict le suaire ne serait âgé que de
700 ans et il aurait donc été
confectionnés au moyen-âge bien qu'elle
ait été demandée par le vatican est
parfaitement accepté par l'église
catholique
cette analyse a évidemment fait couler
beaucoup d'encre et quelques
irréductibles en conteste encore la
validité
alors comment ça marche cette histoire
de carbone 14 est ce qu'on peut s'en
servir pour dater n'importe quoi
des objets ou des fossile aussi vieux
qu'on veut est-ce que ça permettrait de
connaître l'âge de michel drucker
et bien non il ya quand même des limites
à la technique pour les comprendre on va
s'intéresser aux principes physiques qui
se cache derrière la datation au carbone
14 et on illustrera ça avec
quelques-unes de ses utilisations les
plus célèbres en archéologie
[Musique]
alors commençons par quelques rappels
les atomes qui nous entourent sont fait
deux protons et de neutrons qui forment
le noyau atomique et autour duquel on
trouve des électrons dans l'état de base
le nombre d'électrons est égal au nombre
de protons et c'est lui qui détermine la
nature chimique de l'atome
de quels éléments il s'agit dans le
tableau périodique par exemple avec deux
protons c'est de l'hélium
si proton du carbone 8 proton de
l'oxygène 26 proton du fer etc
mais le nombre de neutrons et bien ça
dépend dans un noyau il y en a en gros à
peu près autant que de protons mais il
peut exister plusieurs variantes d'un
même élément
on appelle cela les isotopes de cet
élément prenons l'exemple de l'hélium
son noyau contient toujours deux protons
mais il peut avoir entre 1 et 8 neutrons
alors pour distinguer ces différents
isotopes
on leur attribue un numéro qui est la
somme du nombre de protons et de
neutrons de l'hélium avec un seul
neutrons c'est de l'hélium 3 de neutrons
de l'hélium 4,3 neutrons de l'ayguade 5
etc
à noter la façon dont on l'écrit
traditionnellement on place ce nombre en
haut avant le symbole de l'élément en
théorie on peut imaginer d'état
d'isotopes pour un même élément du
tableau périodique mais en pratique
seuls quelques-uns existe et la plupart
sont instables dans le cas de l'hélium
seul l'hélium 3 et l'hélium quatre sont
stables et on les trouve à l'état
naturel dans des proportions très
différentes
l'immense majorité c'est de l'hélium 4
et seul un atome d'hélium sur un million
et de l'hélium 3 les autres isotopes de
l'hélium sont instables c'est-à-dire
qu'ils finissent toujours par se
transformer en autre chose
prenons le cas de l'hélium 6-2 proton
cap neutrons et bien au bout d'un moment
un des neutrons va se transformer en
proton en émettant un électron et donc
le noyau va globalement devenir un noyau
de lithium 6 et oui il ya maintenant
trois proton donc on change d'éléments
dans le tableau périodique
prenons un autre élément l'oxygène qui
contient huit proton sont isotopes
stables le plus abondant c'est l'oxygène
16 avec 8 neutrons mais son isotope avec
seulement 7 neutrons l'oxygène 15 lui
est instable
il se transforme en azote 15 c'est à
dire que cette fois un proton s'est
transformé en un neutron en émettant un
positron au passage chaque fois qu'il ya
une transformation de ce type
les particules et les rayonnements qui
sont émis peuvent causer des dommages
aux matériaux aux cellules vivantes et
c'est ce qu'on appelle la radioactivité
et on parle donc de désintégrations
radioactives
le terme francophone de désintégration
est parfois un peu trompeur car il peut
laisser penser que les noyaux instable
disparaissent ou explose en plein de
morceaux alors qu'il s'agit juste de
transformation un point essentiel pour
notre histoire c'est que bien qu'elles
se produisent dans les isotopes instable
ces transformations ne sont pas toujours
immédiate
prenons un tas d'atomes d'oxygène 15
imaginons qu'on en ait mis leur départ
si on attend 10 secondes en moyenne 5 %
de ces noyaux vont se désintégrer il en
restera donc environ 950 et ensuite
toutes les dix secondes se sont à chaque
fois 5 % des noyaux d'oxygène 15
restants qui se désintègre comme il
reste de moins en moins au fur et à
mesure il y à aussi de moins en moins d
intégration la courbe du nombre d'atomes
restant va donc ressembler à ça c'est
une des croissances exponentielles pour
caractériser le rythme de cette
décroissance on regarde le temps qu'il
faut pour que la moitié du temps initial
et disparus c'est ce qu'on appelle la
demi vie de l'isotope dans le cas de
l'oxygène 15
on peut voir sur la courbe de
décroissance que sept 2010 et d'environ
120 secondes soit deux minutes par une
chose importante à avoir en tête
concernant cette désintégration
c'est qu'il s'agit d'un phénomène
aléatoire on pourrait s'imaginer que les
noyaux instable vieillissent et quand
ils ont passé un certain âge 10
désintègre mais non la désintégration
radioactive est un truc spontanée est
complètement imprévisible à chaque
instant qui passe chaque noyau à une
certaine probabilité de se désintégrer
mais autrement ils changent pas du tout
alors petite parenthèse pour les fans de
mécanique quantique une manière de
comprendre ce caractère aléatoire c'est
de le voir comme un phénomène d'effet
tunnel comme je les dis on quantifie le
rythme des désintégrations radioactives
à l'aide de la demi vie le temps qu'il
faut pour que la moitié des noyaux ce
soit désintégrer ça ne dépend pas de la
quantité qui a au départ mais ça va
dépendre de l'isotope sept 2010 est donc
d'environ deux minutes pour l'oxygène 15
mais ça peut être très très variable
pour les lionnes 5 la demi vie et d'une
yourte au seconde alors uni octo seconde
c'est un millionième de
a redit m de milliardième de seconde
c'est pas beau à l'opposé pour le
tellure 128 la demi vie ces deux yachts
à année c'est à dire 2 millions de
milliards de milliards d'années
donc si vous prenez un kilo de tellure
128 et que vous le regardez pendant un
an
il ya peut-être un de ces atomes qui va
se désintégrer
alors là je vous donne des cas extrêmes
mais des isotopes instable il en existe
plein de tous les éléments du tableau
périodique avec dès 2010 très variable
et parmi eux le fameux carbone 14 le
carbone c'est le sixième élément du
tableau périodique il possède donc si
proton et suivant le nombre de neutrons
on a différents isotopes vous en voyez
ici une liste non exhaustive avec les
2010 associé le carbone 12 est stable et
c'est le plus courant puisqu'il
représente 99% du carbone qu'on trouve
sur terre le carbone 13 est stable
également
mais c'est seulement un pour cent du
total quant au fameux carbone 14
eh bien il n'est pas stable mais sa demi
vie est vraiment longue
5730 ans ça veut dire quoi imaginons que
vous ayez un tas de carbone 14
si vous attendez 5730 ans il n'en
restera plus que la moitié 50% au bout
de onze mille quatre cent soixante ans
la moitié de la moitié dont 25% et à 17
milles 180 disant seulement 12 5% et
c'est la coupe complète est une
exponentielle décroissante avec une demi
vie de cinq mille sept cent trente ans
et vous voyez peut-être qu'avec ce
principe y doit y avoir moyen d'estimer
l'âge de quelque chose en regardant la
quantité de carbone 14 qui lui reste
plus il est vieux moi il doit en avoir
et oui sauf que pour ça il faudrait
connaître la quantité qu'il y en avait
au départ et en plus cinq mille sept
cent trente ans ça paraît long mais à
l'échelle de l'univers c'est pas grand
chose donc tout le carbone 14 de
l'univers devrait déjà sept désintégrer
non et bien ce qui donne la réponse à
ces questions
c'est que du carbone 14 il en est
produit en permanence dans l'atmosphère
cela provient du fait que les rayons
cosmiques viennent frapper les molécules
de l'air et transforme notamment
certains noyaux d'azoté en carbone 14 ce
carbone se retrouvent ensuite rapidement
lié à de l'oxygène et forme une molécule
de co2 qui vient se mêler aux autres
molécules de co2 de l'atmosphère
donc d'un côté le carbone 14 des intègre
naturellement
de l'autre il est produit dans
l'atmosphère par les rayons cosmiques
la conseil
de cela c'est que le tout carbone 14
dans le co2 de l'atmosphère reste à peu
près constant c'est un taux très faible
10 puissance moins 12
ça veut dire que seulement un atome de
carbone sur mille milliards est un atome
de carbone 14
alors maintenant imaginez une plante qui
pousse tout le temps où elle est vivante
elle fait de la photosynthèse
donc elles absorbent le co2 de
l'atmosphère avec ça elle renouvelle en
permanence l'ensemble des molécules qui
la composent et son taux de carbone 14
reste donc constant égal au taux de
l'atmosphère mais le jour où cette
plante meurt disons qu'elle est coupé
pour en faire quelque chose il n'ya plus
de photosynthèse ni de renouvellement du
carbone donc le taux de carbone 14 va
commencer à décroître
du fait de la désintégration radioactive
et ce d'autant plus que le temps passe
évidemment avec la chaîne alimentaire ce
raisonnement s'étant facilement aux
animaux le taux de carbone 14 dans un
animal qui se nourrit de végétaux va
être essentiellement constant est égal
au taux de l'atmosphère et par extension
pareil pour les carnivores et noter que
ça marche aussi pour les espèces marines
puisque le co2 de l'atmosphère se
dissout dans l'océan
on retrouve à peu près le même taux chez
les plantes et les animaux marins
au total on peut donc dire que
globalement chez les êtres vivants
le taux de carbone 14 est
essentiellement constant est connue tant
qu'ils sont vivants et une semaine à
décroître que quand il meurt donc ce que
nous permet la datation au carbone 14 ce
n'est pas tellement de connaître l'âge
d'un objet mais de savoir depuis combien
de temps la matière qu'ils composent
n'est plus vivante
donc ça marche quand il s'agit de peaux
animales de bois de fibres textiles
végétal éventuellement dos ou de
coquillages
donc quand on connaît le taux de carbone
14 un objet ancien par rapport au taux
de l'atmosphère en pourcentage on prend
la courbe de décroissance et en
reportant on peut en quelque sorte lui
dire son âge avec un taux égal à 80 % du
taux atmosphérique l'objet date d'il ya
environ 2000 ans si ces 30% environ dix
mille ans 10% pas loin de vingt mille
ans etc
mais par contre attention vous ne
pourrez pas dater une épée en bronze au
carbone 14
ben oui y'a pas de carbone dedans un
diamant non plus d'ailleurs même si
celui ci est effectivement composé de
carbone
ça n'est pas du carbone d'origine
biologique donc il ne contient pas de
carbone 14
ah oui du coup le carbone 14 ça marche
pas
plus pour dater michel drucker puisque
aux dernières nouvelles il est toujours
vivant
je vous raconte tout ça en faisant comme
si c'était facile de mesurer la quantité
de carbone 14
mais en fait ça l'est pas du tout on l'a
dit le taux dans l'atmosphère est super
faible c'est autour de 10 puissance
moins 12
un atome de carbone sur mille milliards
donc si en plus une partie s'est
désintégrée il faut être capable de
mesurer sa avec une précision très
importante
une façon de conter la quantité de
carbone 14 dans un échantillon c'est de
mesurer son activité radioactive
bah oui puisque le carbone 14 désintègre
plus aux mesures de radioactivité plus
il ya de carbone 14
le problème c'est qu'il y en a déjà pas
beaucoup alors pour qu une quantité
significative se désintègre il faut
effectuer la mesure sur un échantillon
assez gros seins au moins quelques
dizaines de grammes et pendant plusieurs
jours l'autre façon de faire c'est ce
qu'on appelle la spectrométrie de masse
on va compter les atomes de carbone en
les triant par masse et oui car une des
spécificités du carbone 14 puisqu'il
contient huit neutrons au lieu de six
c'est justement d'être plus lourd que le
carbone 12 pour faire ça on met pas les
atomes sur une balance mais on en fait
un faisceau qu'on propulse dans un champ
magnétique pour le dévier les noyaux les
plus lourds ont plus d'inertie ils
seront donc moins dévier ce qui permet
de séparer le faisceau et de contes et
indépendamment chaque isotopes la
spectrométrie de masse al'avantage de
bien mieux compter les noyaux de carbone
14 et donc permet d'utiliser des
échantillons d'une masse beaucoup plus
faibles souvent moins d'un gramme bien
on a donc vu les grands principes de la
datation au carbone 14
mais vous en voyez aussi les limites
d'une part on ne peut pas datées
n'importe quoi et d'autre part pour des
objets trop vieux et bien ça ne marche
pas imaginons un objet ayant 50 mille
ans sur la courbe on peut lire que 99,9
pour cent de ces atomes de carbone 14
seront désintégrer sachant qu'au départ
le carbone 14 ne représentait déjà qu'un
atome de carbone sur mille milliards
ça fait qu'il en reste un atome de
carbone 14 pour un million de milliards
d'atomes un million de milliards c'est
en gros le nombre de cheveux humains sur
terre
donc c'est comme retrouver un cheveu en
particulier sur l'ensemble des humains
de la planète
bref en gros au delà de 50 mille ans les
techniques de carbone 14 ne sont plus
applicables
ça se voit d'ailleurs parce que si on
prend des hydrocarbures fossiles qui ont
été des plantes un média
longtemps et bien il n'en contiennent
plus du tout le taux de carbone 14 du
pétrole c'est zéro en plus des
limitations convient de voir il faut
savoir qu'il existe un certain nombre de
difficultés qui rendent la technique
plus ou moins précises un problème assez
évident c'est le risque de contamination
imaginons que vous vouliez date et un
petit morceau de textile retrouvaient
dans un vieux tombeau si vous tripoter
l'échantillon et que vous laissez de la
grèce de vos doigts vous allez apporter
du carbone 14 récent ce qui va biaiser
les mesures et plus l'échantillon est
vieux plus une contamination risque de
fausser le résultat une autre difficulté
c'est que contrairement à ce que j'ai
dit le taux de carbone 14 dans les
organismes vivants n'est pas toujours
exactement égal à celui de l'atmosphère
chimiquement un atome de carbone 14
c'est comme un atome de carbone 12 il
subit les mêmes réactions
mais comme il est un peu plus lourd
certains processus peuvent se dérouler à
un rythme légèrement différente par
rapport au carbone aux par exemple la
photosynthèse sera plus fréquentes avec
le carbone 12 mai au contraire la
dissolution dans les océans sera plus
facile avec le carbone 14
il ya donc des petites corrections à
appliquer l'autre truc qui rend
difficile des estimations précises c'est
que je vous ai dit que le taux de
carbone 14 dans l'atmosphère était
essentiellement constants du fait de la
production en continu par les rayons
cosmiques
mais en fait on sait que ce taux a très
légèrement varier au cours des siècles
ce qui peut fausser les estimations ce
sont des choses qu'on a pu constater et
mesurée grâce aux anneaux de certains
arbres très ancien et qui ont ensuite
permis de créer des courbes de
calibration
ce sont des courbes permettant de
corriger les estimations pour tenir
compte des très légère variation du taux
de carbone 14
au cours des siècles alors je parle de
très légères variations mais ça c'était
avant
en effet depuis quelques temps ce taux a
beaucoup varié à cause de nous les
humains premièrement on brûle des
énergies fossiles qui rejette pas mal de
co2 dans l'atmosphère et on l'a dit il
n'ya essentiellement plus de carbone 14
dans les hydrocarbures fossiles
donc ça fait baisser le taux de carbone
14 atmosphérique mais bon al'inverse on
a fait un autre truc qui met bien le
bazar c'est de faire péter des bombes
nucléaires dans l'atmosphère
à partir des années 1950 le taux de
carbone 14 dans l'atmosphère est monté
en flèche à cause de ça et ça n'a
commencé à décroître qu'à partir de 1963
la date du traité qui a banni les essais
nucléaires
en surface autant dire que les
archéologues du cinquième millénaire qui
voudront faire de la datation au carbone
14 sur notre civilisation
eh bien ils vont s'amuser pour recaler
les courbes ah oui la dernière
difficulté quand le taux de carbone 14
varie dans l'atmosphère ça ne se
répercute pas instantanément dans
l'océan surtout en profondeur il peut y
avoir un décalage de plusieurs siècles
ce qui complique encore les calibration
mais bref partons du principe que les
spécialistes de la datation arrive à
corriger au mieux tous ses effets
perturbateurs et voyons ce qu'on a pu
faire avec
[Musique]
la technique de datation au carbone 14 a
été imaginé dans les années 1940 par le
chimiste américain où ils arguent libye
ça lui a valu d'ailleurs le prix nobel
en 1960
au départ on n'avait pas de certitudes
quant à la capacité de cette technique à
faire des datations précise libye a donc
commencé par prendre des vestiges
archéologiques dont on connaissait assez
bien la date et à montrer que la
datation au carbone 14 conduisait à des
résultats similaires à ce qu'on avait
déjà les datations archéologiques ont
permis de valider la technique du
carbone 14 et on verra que maintenant ça
se passe plutôt dans l'autre sens une
des utilisations les plus fameuses du
carbone 14
ça a été la datation des manuscrits de
la mer morte
il s'agit d'un grand ensemble de
parchemin et de papyrus qui ont été
retrouvés dans des grottes en palestine
entre les années 1946 et 1956 sur ces
parchemins on a trouvé notamment de
nombreux textes de la bible hébraïque ce
que les religions chrétiennes appellent
l'ancien testament
jusqu'ici le plus ancien manuscrit connu
de ces textes c'était le codex d'alep
dont on estime qu'il a été écrit entre
l'an 910 et 932 notre ère évidemment à
la découverte des manuscrits la mer
morte
on a voulu connaître leur âge pour
savoir où il se situait par rapport à ça
et bien le carbone 14 a permis de les
dater les plus vieux aurait été écrit en
moins de 150
c'est à dire plus de mille ans avant le
codex d'alec un bond dans le passé
incroyable d'une importance capitale
pour ceux qui étudie la façon dont ces
textes religieux ont évolué au cours des
siècles alors un point toutefois dans
cette histoire la réponse n'est pas venu
seulement du carbone 14
mais également de ce qu'on appelle la
paléographie c'est-à-dire l'étude d
écriture manuscrite anciennes et cette
méthode a donné des résultats similaires
au carbone 14 pour estimer l'âge des
parchemins
c'est important car souvent sur des
questions compliquées comme les
datations archéologiques
il faut utiliser une combinaison de
techniques pour affiner les estimations
le carbone 14 n'a pas toujours seule
réponse à tout un autre exemple célèbre
de datation c'est celui de ce qu'on
appelle la carte du vinland il s'agit
d'une drôle de mappemonde dessiné sur un
parchemin qui a fait surface à la fin
des années 50 et représente supposément
le monde connu aux environs du xiiie
siècle
le truc bizarre il
à regarder on voit le groenland pour ok
mais plus à l'ouest ce qui représentait
comme une sorte de deal avec deux larges
aux embouchures des fleuves
ça évoque quand même furieusement la
côte est de l'amérique du nord ont xiiie
siècle l'endroit est noté comme étant le
vineland est ce le nom qu'aurait donné
le viking life ericsson à un territoire
qu'il a explorés autour de l'an mil et
dont on pense qu'il s'agit justement du
nord de l'amérique
on a d'ailleurs retrouvé depuis des
vestiges vikings sur les côtes de
terre-neuve au canada
si on croit à l'authenticité de ce
document ce serait donc une trace de la
cartographie des côtes de l'amérique du
nord par les vikings et ce bien avant
christophe colomb alors qu'andy le
carbone 14 est bien des analyses menées
sur le parchemin ont permis de le dater
d'une façon assez précise entre 1423 et
1445 donc clairement avant christophe
colomb sauf que sauf que cette datation
ne concerne que le parchemin le support
de la carte
imaginez que le parchemin soit
effectivement anciens mais que le tracé
soit info réalisé au xxème siècle pour
savoir ça il faudrait analyser lancre
mais c'est pas possible de faire une
datation au carbone 14 qui porte juste
sur l'encré alors depuis des analyses
chimiques ont quand même révélé que
cette encre contiendrait d'ailleurs du
dioxyde de titane un composé qu'on sait
fabriquer que depuis 1920 ce qui jette
un sérieux doute sur l'authenticité de
la carte
mais bon aujourd'hui le débat n'est pas
encore complètement tranché
dans la même veine le carbone 14 a aussi
permis de dater le fameux manuscrit voie
unique
un livre écrit dans un code que personne
n'a encore réussi à déchiffrer et qui
aurait donc été écrit entre 1404 et 1438
parmi les autres datation fameuse il ya
aussi ce qu'on appelle l'évangile de
judas
il s'agit d'un manuscrit en papyrus
présentant un évangile attribué à judas
iscariote l'apôtre qui a trahi jésus
c'est ce qu'on appelle un évangile
apocryphe c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas
reconnu par l'église catholique
et pour cause il présente l'histoire
sous un jour assez différent puisque
dans cet évangile judas aurait trahi sur
ordre de jésus
toujours est il qu'on a pu analyser ce
manuscrit au carbone 14 et il date du
troisième siècle troisième siècle après
jésus-christ évidemment dans les usages
plus académique du carbone 14
on peut mentionner cette récente étude
d'envergure qui en deux
10 a permis de réviser et d'ajuster
toute la chronologie de l'egypte
ancienne
je voulais 10 initialement il a fallu
valider la technique du carbone 14 à
partir d'objets dont on connaissait
approximativement la date
et bien maintenant la méthode est si
efficace qu'elle permet de venir
compléter voire réviser certaines
estimations archéologiques faut dire
qu'en ce qui concerne l'egypte ancienne
c'est assez compliqué quand on doit
faire des datations et notamment établir
une chronologie des pharaons on se base
en général sur des textes écrits ont
sauf qu'on en a déjà pas forcément à
l'appel et en plus à l'époque les
scribes avait une fâcheuse tendance à
rebuter les dates chaque fois qu'il y
avait un nouveau pharaon
on comptait les années à partir du début
du règne du souverain
grâce à ça on a parfois des bonnes
estimations relatives entre les
événements mais ça n'est pas du tout
évident de positionner le tout sur un
calendrier absolue d'attribuer des
années précise aux différents règne
prenons un exemple un le célèbre pharaon
khéops
celui qui a construit la grande pyramide
de gizeh on pense que son règne a duré
entre 25 et 45 ans et que c'était
quelque part ou 26ème siècle avant notre
ère donc entre moins de 1600 et moins de
1500 mais il ya un débat autour de la
date précise d'après la chronologie
établie par l'égyptologue ian show son
règne aurait commencé en moins de 1589
mais d'après la chronologie d'eric
hornung un autre égyptologue ce serait
plutôt moins 2509 ça fait 80 ans de
différence quand même et récemment une
nouvelle théorie a été proposée en se
basant sur l'orientation de la pyramide
de khéops par rapport aux points
cardinaux et a avancé une estimation
encore plus récente - 2480 bon donc en
gros on as en temps d'incertitudes sur
le début du règne de khéops et pour tous
les pharaons on a ce genre de problèmes
surtout pour les plus anciennes
dynasties on a du mal à mettre des dates
absolue met donc en 2010 une grande
étude a essayé de mettre tout le monde
d'accord
l'idée était d'utiliser une méthode
prenant en compte à la fois les données
archéologiques et de nouvelles mesures
au carbone 14 qui se voulait le plus
précise possible pour ça les auteurs ont
notamment choisi d'utiliser
préférentiellement des graines et des
textiles
car ils permettent d'avoir des
estimations plus précises que des objets
par exemple en bout
ah oui prenez un vieil arbre même s'il
est toujours vivant seules les corses et
les feuilles vont se renouveler
mais ça n'est pas le cas pour le coeur
du tronc qui est en quelque sorte déjà
mort bah oui un pont saisi un arbre
vivant en fait à l'intérieur il est déjà
mort un peu comme michel drucker et donc
si un pharaon s'est taillé un sceptre en
bois dans le coeur d'un vieil arbre et
s'est fait enterrer avec et bien l'âge
de l'arbre peut fausser beaucoup la
datation
d'où l'idée de n'utiliser que des choses
qui laissent moins d' ambiguïté comme
des graines grâce à 200 datation de ce
genre l'étude a fournit une estimation
de la date de début de règne d'une
quarantaine de farm couvrant une période
allant de moins de 1600 à moins 1100
c'est à dire du début de l'ancien empire
à la fin du nouvel empire
voici une représentation graphique des
résultats en abscisse vous avez les
dates et on voit les trois périodes
correspondantes ancien empire moyen
empire et nouvel empire et dans chacune
de ces périodes vous avez une liste des
principaux souverains la position
verticale c'est juste l'ordre
chronologique pour chaque souverain ou
voit une petite barque rouge qui indique
l'estimation de début de règne d'après
l'égyptologue reagan show en bleu
d'après eric or nous et envers d'après
la théorie sur l'orientation des
pyramides et par dessus tout ça la
courbe grise et représente la
distribution de probabilité du début de
règne
calculé par l'étude la date la plus
probable est au pic de la courbe et la
largeur de la courbe mesure en gros
l'incertitude prenons l'exemple de
khéops dont le nom égyptien et qufu on
voit que l'estimation de l'étude colle
très bien avec la chronologie rouge
celle de ryan shaw et semble en
désaccord net avec les deux autres
estimations
on retrouve à peu près le même phénomène
sur tous les souverains de l'ancien
empire et sur les derniers l'estimation
est même encore plus antérieure à la
chronologie de chaud pour les souverains
du moyen empire c'est pareil en moins
prononcé et pour le nouvel empire bay on
voit que les courbes sont plus
resserrées on a moins d'incertitudes car
la période est plus récente
évidemment il se pourrait que les choses
bougent encore un peu avec 2
nouvelle mesure où de nouvelles
découvertes mais avoir une chronologie
absolue plus fiable à de nombreux
avantages
ça permet par exemple de mieux comparer
l'histoire de l'égypte ancienne avec
celle des civilisations voisines comme
la mésopotamie et donc en quelque sorte
de pouvoir recoller les deux chronologie
de façon absolue cependant comme on l'a
dit le carbone 14 a ses limites et il ne
permet pas par exemple de dattes et des
vestiges datant de plus de 50 mille ans
en histoire ça va mais pour les fossiles
des paléoanthropologues ça devient
compliqué heureusement il existe
d'autres méthodes par exemple celle du
béryllium 10 il s'agit d'un isotope dont
la demi vie est de 1,4 million d'années
il est lui aussi produit dans
l'atmosphère mais se retrouve sur les
sols du fait des précipitations ce qui
permet de dater des sédiments
c'est notamment grâce à cette technique
qu'il a été possible de dater le
squelette de toumaï le plus ancien
fossile connu de la lignée humaine dont
l'âge est ainsi est estimé à sept
millions d'années soit plus du double de
l'âge de la célèbre lucy et sinon je
pourrais aussi vous parler de la
datation à l'uranium plomb qui a permis
d'estimer l'âge du plus vieil objet
terrestre connue une roche de zircon
vieille de 4,4 milliards d'années mais
bon on va quand même pas commencé à
parler cailloux sur cette chaîne voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui vous
trouverez comme toujours des compléments
et précision dans le billet de blog qui
accompagne la vidéo
abonnez vous mêler la cloche tout ça et
je vous dis à très vite pour des
nouvelles vidéos à bientôt
[Musique]